starbuck island i have come ashore with
National Geographic photographer Brian
scary an assistant
Mauricio handler to meet conservationist
Mike Fay Mike has spent three days on
Starbuck one of the most remote islands
in the world to document wildlife here
flat and baking hot the islands coral
rubble supports a unique ecosystem
uninhabited for more than 140 years
evidence from the days of mining one
used to make gunpowder still exists from
ditches to dwellings each structure
built by hand rock by rock the only
trees palms planted by long-gone workers
my pax his meager provisions ready for
the swim from shore it's the only way on
or off Starbuck most of the year further
isolating the tiny at home but we get
some bad news
we will not from that swim in the water
this is our to RAF we're stuck without
food or water
on the ship our teammates swing into
action to help us